what is the number one lesson that you
want to instill in your children one day
it's treating humans with respect
treating animals with respect it says a
lot about you and it starts at a very
very young age that's why Legacy that
would make me very happy looks like
Kaley Cuoco is getting started on her
Legacy she's officially a mom I give you
a little baby fever
are cute and everyone
adorable Kaylee welcomes a baby girl her
first child with Tom Pell free I just
love it she confirmed the pregnancy news
on Instagram in October writing quote
baby girl pill free coming 2023 Beyond
blessed and over the moon I love you Tom
Pelfrey
and of course the announcement came with
a ton of cute pics
like this shot of the couple posing with
some cake pink frosting included in this
sweet snap of their mama bear and papa
bear mugs I'm so excited someone else
who's excited about Kaylee's journey to
Motherhood fundamental problem with
Elementary quantum mechanical formalism
is that the Fourier transform extends to
minus infinity in time hey don't dumb
this down for me
her Big Bang Theory co-star Jim Parsons
she was a mother-like figure to me for
many years on Big Bang even though I'm
tremendously older than her and no it's
true and uh yeah how would she mother
you
she was just she's a comforting presence
and um you know I don't know I don't
know it was a pleasure to work with her
day in and day out she's a very warm
person I think that child's lucky to
have her for a mother Kaylee and Tom's
relationship is a True Hollywood love
story you know we met actually it's a
very Hollywood Story we have the same
manager oh I know so we met at the Ozark
Premiere I was actually a guest of my
managers and I went with her was it this
one this last one was their house
well I wasn't exactly on the carpet yeah
no I went inside I was so excited I just
went with my manager and we met there
and it was love at first sight they made
their couple's debut at a Hollywood Walk
of Fame ceremony in May and later that
month Kaylee's flight attending CoStar
and best friend Zasha mehmed gave Tom
her stamp of approval it's really
interesting and she said this from the
beginning I mean I I knew when she knew
anytime you know like any time anything
in our life though we're very on the
same wavelength and so we're so it's
when you're best friends with someone
when you're truly best friends and you
love them that deeply you're so
interconnected and when I met him I was
one of the last meet him I met him and I
was like I feel like I've known you
forever I feel like you've been here and
he loves her like nobody's business and
that's all that matters to me enough
said
I love it
congratulations to the new parents
[Music]
thank you